as you know we've identified another
suspect in uh that in that case in the
uh the salisbury poisonings uh a man
called dennis sergeyev and i just want
to to say that we
do believe that all the suspects should
be handed over for justice and i should
point out to
people in russia who who've been behind
this uh that
russia has already paid a heavy price in
the sense that there was the biggest
ever diplomatic expulsion uh in response
to the cr the three powerpoints
poisonings with 28 countries expelling
153 diplomats around the world but they
should recognize that our sense uh that
justice must be done uh is not abated
and
dawn sturgis an innocent member of the
british public uh died in that event and
we want to see
those suspects handed over prime
minister last winter we had a covert
crisis this winter we might have another
one of those as well as a fuel crisis we
have supply chain disruption from brexit
with a shortage of lorry drivers now
food supplies are warning of shortages
of frozen meats even christmas turkey
due to a sudden charge of carbon dioxide
the perfect storm of brexit covered and
gas shortages leading us to a winter of
discontent
the
problem that we've got at the moment uh
is really a a function of the global
economy uh waking up after a long state
of uh suspended
animation uh
cryogenic freezing during cobit
ships haven't been moving uh trade
hasn't been taking place uh there's a
global shortage of hdv drivers explain
that a lot in
correct and and i totally understand
that and i and i sympathize with
people's anxieties but i do want to
reassure people that supply chains are
very secure and we'll make sure that
we do everything we can to support those
what there are specific issues that the
government needs to address such as
the co2 shortages is important for
various sectors the drinks industry uh
the the uh
the food industry uh we're we're looking
at what we can do to to sort that out
then there's the whole question of the
energy uh price spikes are hydrogen it's
going up price 39 pounds in october
universal credit cards
uh inflation i mean life's getting
harder for britain's under your
premiership isn't it no what you're
seeing you don't actually like getting
higher what you're seeing is
first of all we've got the fastest
growing economy in uh the gcm you don't
think people are having as the oecd has
confirmed and yes i i know how tough it
can be for people at times but we think
that the best way forward for the
country
is
to do
what we're doing now to keep opening up
the economy and what you're seeing there
is wages rising now uh for the first
time in decades
because they've been stagnant for a very
we would much rather see
wages arising faster beth and we would
much rather see people getting paid well
with high-wage high-skill jobs and
controlled immigration
rather than low wages
just in terms of supplies can you
guarantee the lights will stay on people
won't have fuel shortages yes i can
because the british chamber of commerce
have said that the factory is already
discussing a permanent reduction
operating capacity such as three or four
day work in weeks is that going to
happen last winter i'm very confident in
our supply chains i'm very confident
that we'll be able to
keep energy supplies going there there
is a short-term problem caused by the uh
because hydrocarbon the price by the gas
price spike caused basically by the huge
demand in uh in asia uh but the market
beth is going to is going to start
fixing it but in the meantime in the
meantime the government will do
everything we can
to uh help people uh to help fix it to
make sure that we we smooth things out
so far you didn't rule out that this
could take months to resolve now months
to me goes into christmas and all the
shortages part of math is and the like
we're talking about about turkeys
etcetera
is it going to last for months and could
it affect christmas i don't i think
everybody i think the supply chains are
very secure i think that the british
food industry is fantastic
i think the british food industry is
fantastically
i don't think we're going to have any
problems on that scale i think what we
need to do
is no i'm not i think we need to work
very very hard
with the company's concerned to make
sure that we address their problems
that's what quasi quartet the business
secretary is doing just
let's literally clear what's happening
this is a function of growth
that you're seeing around the world
caused by the renewing the returning
that's what we're seeing
are my bills
am i going to have shortages am i not
going to be able to get food is my job
going to be under threat because
factories are having to know because
that's what they're
to convey my reassurance and and and you
know this is i really don't believe that
that is
justified and when you talk about
employment for instance actually what
you're seeing is record numbers of jobs
are being created you're seeing people
coming off uh furlough in huge numbers
and you're you're seeing wages right
which is which is a great thing we're
really short on time
is invest in people's skills
there's no food shortages it's all going
to sort out you're going to sort it out
trade deal can i just quickly move on to
that i was a bit confused about this
because the u.s uk trade deal was a
break a great brexit wing win and now
it's on the back burner you said
president biden has many fish to fry
global britain to you then is small fry
to the us come on death look two i
didn't i think you were you're on the
first trip uh two years ago when the
americans wouldn't even buy british beef
and we've lifted that back yeah but come
on and the one of our most significant
exports is is scotch whiskey uh we've
lifted the tariffs on scotch whiskey we
were fine we had a queue in 2017 and now
you can't guarantee what we're getting
at brexit in five years one of the
biggest and longest running problems in
uh us uk trading relations was the uh
airbus boeing dispute and we fixed it
okay
okay
you're entitled to your gloom uh but
you're wrong because uh what you're
seeing is uh is a massive improvement
let's let i've got a wrap in trading
relations
your big trade deal with the us you
cannot guarantee we've done about 70
free trade deals already and australia's
worth 20 billion and don't forget that
we've already got 200 billion i think
most of your your view our viewers beth
will think that uh it's pretty good to
have lifted the ban on on british beef
uh to have sorted out the scotch whiskey
towers and we're talking about major
exports uh to the to the uk so you're
going to get it done by 2024 we're not
going to commit we will keep going with
free trade deals
including in the united states and i
have you know
but the plenty of uh reason to be
optimistic about that but i just you
know that these the the americans do
negotiate very hard um what i want for
our country is a great free trade deal
i won't settle for anything less well
you might not get it done by your end of
your premiership
we're going to go as fast as we can okay
thank you very much